まあ質問があるならば
まあ一応まあこちらの中にも質問がありましたから
皆様聞きたがっている質問は一応入ってあったと思いますけどね
大体質問されたって もうそれほど立派に私を困らせるぐらいに
まあ質問はあまりしないし
まあまあ それでも何か素朴な質問でもあるならば出してみてください
素朴な質問に難しい答えで
難しい質問に素朴な素朴な答えということになりますけど
はい  社会から学ぶというお話で
うまくいったところをリストアップしていくと
ですけど 悪い方というのはリストアップしない方がいい
悪い方はもうどうせダメだからね
それは関係ないんです
面倒くさいでしょ リスト
例えばいい方で 200項目見つけちゃうと
悪い方法でも 300項目ぐらい見つかるんだから
もうそれだけで 500になるでしょうね
だからもう成功した例だけで十分ですよ
はい  役に立つという話で
小さなところからということで
家族 周りの人 地域 人類
そういう順番で能力開発をしていくという話があったと思うんですけども
その順番を守らなかったらどうなるんでしょう
じゃあ不幸になるね 不幸になるし
一人ぼっちになるし 何一つも成功しないんですよ
だって 自分の今まで生きてきたことも
人の役に立ったことによって成り立ってますよ
もし生まれた時はお母さんを楽しませてあげなかったならば
育ててくれないんだからね
捨てられますからね だから
小さい時でも自分がお母さんの役に立ったんですよ
お父さんの役に立ったんですよ
だからこの二人が まあこいつは世界一可愛いんだとか言いながら
なんて可愛い子でしょうかとか言いながら
もう何でもかんでもやってくれたでしょ
まあそれもそれなりに無意識的でしたけど
子供の頃はね 役に立ったことは役に立ったんですよ
大人になったらそれがうまくいかない
それはケチャップ取りです
無意識的に役に立つことはなくなっちゃうんです
大人になるということは
自分で意識的に自分で役に立つことなんて
子供と大人の差はそちらになるんですよ
子供はいるだけで可愛いんですよ
もう役に立ってるんですよ
うるさい うるさいんだけど
まあそれでも大人から見ればもういるだけで可愛いんですね
だから子供は役に立ってます
自動的に子供が大人になるということは
そこは自分で役に立つようにしなくちゃいけないんです
そこから大人の世界なんです
もう可愛いと思ってくれない
だから まあそんなもんですから
役に立たないようにすると
もう人間失格でもう大体刑務所とかそういうところにいるのはそういう人でしょ
あの この家族とか周りの人たち
会社とか その小さなことからということだったんですけど
例えばその会社に対してにおける能力開発を一生懸命やって
その小さな方を忘れていると
うん 確かにそうすると
今おっしゃったように不幸になるということなのかもしれないですけれども
その辺のバランスとか
どういうことではないんですか？完璧に順番があるんですよ
完璧な順番がありますよ
これ 観念的にはいろいろなことを言われたって
もう実際体を動かす場合は小さなことから動かすんですよ
だから社会とブッダの違うところは
この観念的なことには乗らないところなんですよ
いつでも具体的なところで
例えば大胆なスケールの能力開発
なんかもう紙の上で喋っても
実際は小さなところからやらなくちゃいけないでしょ
例えばまあまあ古い会社ですけど
もうコンピューターシステム導入するんだそうと
すべて電子化するんだそうと
大胆に どんな会社からソフトウェア買うのか
どういうふうにデータ処理するのか
それからどれぐらいそれで会社が利益を得るのかとか
講義するかもしれませんだけど
会社の社員たちはコンピューター触ったことがないならば
初めからもうキーボードを打つことと
ことから始まるでしょ
一応 だから実際は能力開発はもう自分たちがじゃあどうすればいいんでしょうかとかね
あ そうです そうするのとかね
そこから能力開発しますよ
だから ある社員が突然もうコンピューターの授業やら講義やらプログラミングやら
そんなものを勉強しようとしちゃうと
あまりにも観念的で その人はあのターミナル
なんでパソコンを使いなくなっちゃうんですね
だから あんまり大胆なことを考えない方が具体的なんです
それから会社にしたっても
このあの ただ観念的にこのすごい能力開発とかなんとか喋っちゃうと
社員たちはついていけなくなっちゃうんですよ
それで会社潰れちゃいますね
だから 特に会社経営する人々は具体的な商売だから
常に具体的っていうことは覚えておかないと
いつでも頭にどんな妄想が浮かんでも
まず実行できるかないかと
それ考えなきゃ 会社の場合は
まあ実行できなくても
これで黒字になるのかと
それ考えてもらわなきゃ
もうダメでしょう そこでブッダの話っていうのは
社会ではなくて 会社ではなくて
個人に喋ってます だから
会社で何と言おうと 政府は何と言おうと
個人がそれどう生きればいいかという話なんですよ
それでうまくいきます
だから 個人個人が小さなところからじわじわじわじわじわじわと開発していけば
ものの見事に成長していきますよ
その人はしっかりした社会人なんですよ
そういう人っていうのは
もう社会から言えば もう全くのもうもうなくてはならない存在なんですよ
例えば あの頭だけで その今
地球の環境問題とかを考える
それは確かに頭だけで自分でやれることがない
ただ あの 何かしなきゃいけないとか
そういう気持ちだけある
ただ それっていうのは
そのやっぱり足元がぐらついてるような妄想になるでしょ
だと思いますけど 例えばもう今日はすごく暑かったんですけど
私はもう全部カーテン閉めて
部屋はもう光の入らないように真っ黒にしています
なぜかというと それでかなり熱が入らなくなっちゃいます
それで冷房は使わない
それでもちょこっと暑いんだから
ちょこっと扇風機だけ回していて
それで結構涼しいんですけど
そこで微妙に考えるのは
やっぱりエネルギーをできるだけ控えるんだぞと
だから自分にできるところからやればね
水は私は無駄遣いしていませんし
ちょっと話は関係ないんですけど
よく学校で友達と教室があると殴られるんですけど
どうしたらいいんですか？ 友達と
教室があるとよく殴られるんですけど
どうしたらいいんですか？ うーん
ただの男同士の喧嘩でしょ
いやに殴られるの  パッと乗っ取られたり
殴られたり 蹴り決められたりするんですけど
どうしたらいいですか
だから 2つありますけどね 1
つはもう自分でも10倍ぐらい脅すとかね
うーん あるいはもうもう子供でも暴力
違法は違法だから警察に訴えてやるぞとかね
どうしても 例えば極端な話
とんでもない もう悪く
恐ろしくて もうもうものすごく殴るんだったら
うっちゃってやるぞ 自分が椅子とやればいいんです
座り込む 先生たちのもう部屋の前か学校の前か
それいいんです 別に こういうことがあるんだから何とかしようと
それは解決しないまでは絶対立ちませんよと
大体二時間で解決します
こういうのは一人でもできます
だから勇気がないってことでしょう
そういうことを思い浮かんだだけでも勇気があるんですよ
勇気があると大体解決しますよ
まああまりもう男同士で喧嘩するとか
それは決してやめられませんよ
それが楽しいしね あんたもやってるでしょ？結局はね
ね だからまあそれは別にね
もう仲良く喧嘩するんだから
痛いのは痛いんだけど
まあその程度は飛んじゃってね
病気になって恐ろしく攻撃するんだったら
ああいう風に何かしなくちゃいけない
とことん十倍脅してやるか
包丁で刺してやるぞとかね
じゃあやってみろと お前のご飯に明日は毒入れてやるぞとかね
あの アメリカンコーデも
まあこれは青酸カリだとか持っていけばね
それだけで怯えますから
どうせ腰抜けですよ そういう悪いことする人々はね
えらい気が弱いんです
だからアメリカンコーデもちょこっと紙に
で もう青酸カリだと そうやって脅しちゃえば
もうもうなんとかなります
あるいは椅子とやる まあ私はね
子供の頃だったらいきなり先生に喧嘩するんで
あの先生何やってるんでしょうかと
なんとかしてちょうだいよと
言うともう何とかしますよ
それでも日本ではね なんか先生も気が弱いし
親は頭が悪いし もうもうどうにもならんだから
だからPTAに頼んだっても役に立たない
先生に頼んだっても役に立たないしね
だったら十倍やるしかないんです
ちょこっと殴ったら もう殺されたぐらい大騒ぎして泣いて叫んで
もうもう窓ガラスも割っちゃって
いろんなことにも殴られたと
それで殴ったから お前ちょこっと殴っただけではないかと
やばいとやめ やめますよ
そういう何とかを工夫しなくちゃいけないんですよ
うん それで十分だと思います
このもう一つが みんな子供たちに勉強してほしいことは
このいじめとかね 子供同士であるんですけど
本当はそれっていうのは必要なんですよ
大人になるために だからいじめられていいわけじゃなくて
自分がいじめられないように
このこの悪人たちに可愛がってもらうようにどうすればいいかという頭を使うんですよ
そこは身についてくると
大人になってもこの恐ろしい世界で生きていられますよ
大人になったらものすごい残酷ですよ
世界はもう優しくないんです
それに落ち込んじゃうと何もできないんですよ
だから人は批判するわ
もうもうもういろんなことありますよ
だから小さい時からも
もう子供の友達同士でうまくもうからくりできれば
大人になってもその能力を身につくんですよ
だからいじめられても
これは嫌やとかね 学校に行かないぞと思っちゃうと
もう負け なんとか今度こそやってこいとかなんとかするぞと
なんとか考えていった方が
自分が大人になってからはものすごく役に立ちます
ですから そのいじめとかいうのは
いつでもあるんですよ
日本の特別なことじゃないんです
どんな国でも昔からも子供の間であるんです
動物でもお互いにものすごく絡み合って喧嘩したりするでしょ
小さい時は それが必要なんです
大人になるために だからそれが嫌じゃなくて
俺ならどうしようかなというふうに考えることなんです
なんとか工夫してやるぞと
こいつのなんとか落とし穴作ってやるぞとかね
そういう感じでなんとかすればね
いいとは思います はい
はい  まだ少し質問ありますか？では
まあ6時になりましたからね
はい